[Music]
justice has spoke
it's time for a toke supreme court
justice clarence thomas says it's time
to end federal marijuana prohibition
because the current laws on the books no
longer make sense and i agree especially
after that brownie i had in the green
room
thanks harris you got a great connection
oh yeah at issue it's too late not
at issue is the mixed messaging and
legality between the state and federal
level medical marijuana is available in
36 states and full recreational use in
18.
and like my massive fan base those
numbers only continue to grow
stop it so
meanwhile federal tax laws prevent weed
businesses from deducting business
expenses
like advertising or hydroponic lights
and nachos
so while weed growers want high
customers the government wants high
taxes
yet the feds have been told by the
department of justice not to go after
weed businesses that follow state law
figure that out
as justice thomas explained quote the
federal government's current approach is
half in half out regime that
simultaneously tolerates and forbids
local use of marijuana
then he started giggling and stared at
his hand for 15 minutes
but it's like my dad used to say you
know maybe it's time to read the writing
on the wall
which at our place was always please
call the police i'm being held against
my will
stupid grifters anyway um
where am i going with it harris i don't
know i don't know
where you stand on this i believe that
this is inevitable
and i think it's a good thing because
then you're able to create quantifiable
manageable products
all right so i am not the authority
that you may think i am on the weed
not even though i'm dressed like
sporties call it the weeds yeah
right exactly and i'm dressed like a
plant
but i you know i'm curious about this
why does it get the same legal
designation as like lsd
yeah it's really good points heroin i
mean again i'm
i'm not although my dress is the exact
same color as the word marijuana
yes um i i'm not really familiar with
the inner workings of the weed but i
think it's not like lsd or heroin
so i i kind of get where the justice is
going
with this all of them though if you you
mentioned
cat if you mention heroin or or acid
all of these things the solution is
always the con the quantifial
quantifiable measurement and purity of a
drug always makes it
safer yep harm reduction absolutely and
it's also
you know a personal choice and a lot of
the problems
with you know people talk about the
opiate crisis without even mentioning
that it's fentanyl that's in street
drugs because people like you said they
don't know
what they're taking um i think that
you know it's marijuana certainly not
the same as heroin or
lsd but i also think that they should
all be you know completely legalized
and you know for the marijuana thing
most people i mean 60
in a poll from just a couple months ago
they think it should be completely
legalized
i think we should go ahead and do it and
the great news for the people who
disagree
is it will still be legal for them to
not use it right right
that's due to the drug cartels that's
crazy yeah exactly
and look the idea of a good chemical and
a bad chemical is flawed
it's just flawed they are just chemicals
and they're
the human relationship with them if you
have fentanyl and you're a pancreatic
cancer patient
you're damn glad you got fentanyl if
you're a heroin addict it will kill you
right it's not because the chemicals
good or bad it's just a quality of the
human relationship with it
and cannabis is no different and it's
you're exactly correct it's inevitable
it's inevitable and are states like
california where i hearken
from spiraling out of control because we
have recreational cannabis
no in fact i would argue that people are
getting more realistic about it because
they've gotten all that political energy
out of it and now you can talk about it
realistically and the problems the risks
and the benefits it's true it's like pro
when prohibition
i mean there were people running for
president under the prohibition
name i mean it was that political and
then once it went away it's just like
this
it was like a dream that just kind of
ended and i also think the same thing is
happening with colorado too is that
colorado you were thinking
you're being told oh my god everybody's
high but then it was just like there was
some kind of
pot tourism and then everybody was like
it became as mundane as a martini
tyrus sure yeah yeah definitely i don't
know much about weed but uh i believe a
qp a day keeps the doctor away
what's your qp i don't know what that is
i know you don't you said the weed
[Laughter]
definitely no i wouldn't be knocking on
your door going uh you got a dime bag
doc
not that i would ever do anything but
then again when i'm in california you
bet your ass i will
that's the confusing part yeah if it's
legal here illegal there
you know it's it's tough but here's the
deal if you take the history lesson back
why was it made illegal in the first
place because the settlers wanted to
make cotton and tobacco
and they couldn't compete with native
americans so they made it illegal
because you could make hemp and clothes
they're out of marijuana so it was a
racist history yeah so here we go yeah
so we'll be woke
yeah free it up and here's a great idea
tax it can pay for the infrastructure
boom done flat tax across the board put
it in the schools
put it in our streets the money in the
schools he means
yeah 20 minutes at this point i'll take
a high teacher
i'll be really would opposed to the
political one who's telling me that
my neighbor is racist because he was
born white
so i'd rather see the high version where
everyone's beautiful and cool
and extra art class they're all
psychedelic is that how it works
no he's right yeah if if
everybody like it's hard to be angry
after a really good
edible like if you're just like people
like i bet you could solve more
doctors no no i'm just saying the bar
fights happen on alcohol
exactly what are you going to say you
talk about chemicals yeah alcohol
businesses that never get off the ground
yes the worst thing about
businesses yeah like our new show racist
house
that was born from where probably some
weed
by the way racist haunted house yes i
actually was going to bring it up in the
e block about how our progress is going
we're starting a racist
haunted house i'm in for halloween i
mean he had to explain that to me
i don't care
racist haunted house you just line up it
was never ghosts
it was always the racist house yes
welcome to the show
thank you